les français vont beaucoup entendre
parler ces jours-ci d'informatique avec
le sicop qui veut ouvrir ses portes avec
le grand colloque du palais des congrès
sur l'informatique et ses différentes
applications et un discours de clôture
du président de la république lui-même
cette semaine monsieur norbert segard le
secrétaire d'état aux ptt à présenter
monsieur télématique françois henrot
dans la mission est de coordonner le
développement des applications de la
télématique l'ordinateur dans la vie
quotidienne de définir des projets
nouveaux et de les faire aboutir la
vitesse betty bureau pour cette lettre à
l'an 2000 aujourd'hui sur la télématique
et monsieur norbert ce gars le
secrétaire d'état aux ptt élima clic la
révolution et pour demain on peut même
dire pour aujourd'hui dans votre domaine
les téléphones le petit écran à
l'ordinateur
mais sommes-nous prêts réellement nous
les français à comprendre cette mutation
technologique qui va s'opérer maintenant
sous nous yeux c'est le mariage entre
l'informatique et le téléphone et
télécommunications l'informatique qu'est
ce que c'est essentiellement ces jeux
qu'on appelle le tactiquement des
plaques donné c'est à dire des stocks de
plusieurs millions d'informations et que
l'on peut extraire en quelques
millionièmes de secondes donc
instantanément et des télécommunications
vous le savez c'est la communication
instantanée à distance le mariage des
deux fait donc que on peut envoyer à
distance à la demande de l'intéressé
parmi des millions de renseignement
désiré le renseignement vous en clair si
j'ose dire en quoi cela risque-t-il de
modifier notre vie de tous les jours la
vie des français quotidienne
ce quelque chose de considérable grâce
par exemple à ce poste à clavier qui est
l'élément indispensable chez le
particulier pourra voir ce qu'on appelle
le terminal de l'ordinateur c'est de
pouvoir téléphoner pour eva leurs
enseignements qu'on veut à cet
ordinateur alors qu'actuellement on ne
peut pas d'ordinateur et dans des gros
centres et par conséquent le particulier
pourra voir instantanément des
renseignements s'il veut voyager dans
des agences de voyages s'il veut avoir
des prix
pour les halles à faire ce renseignement
et pour avoir n'importe quel numéro de
téléphone de france et en sachant qu'il
aura le renseignement précis non pas
d'un annuaire qui peut dater de ce débat
il peut dépasser il peut avoir son
compte en banque
autrement dit il ya la possibilité pour
chaque particulier de pouvoir être
renseignées dans le domaine qu'ils
désirent instantanément et avec la plus
grande efficacité possible
encore faut-il avoir les téléphones
madone en 3 4 en deux temps nous avons
déjà créé autant de téléphones que
pendant les cent premières heures nous
sommes passés de 6 millions de lignes
que nous avons en 74 plus de 13 me en
maintenant gendron 20 millions 82 30
millions 90 c'est à dire que niveau de
la densité
nous aurons un teint a dépassé les pays
les plus industrialisés et nous savons
faire toute une politique même par les
prix en les diminuant d'incitation à ce
que les français et le téléphone
c'est devenu un instrument indispensable
de la vie personnelle sociale culturelle
des françaises et des français et ce qui
est tout à fait fascinante
c'est qu'on pourrait voir aussi dans
normand les mois prochain dans les
années à venir
son correspondant téléphonique sur
l'écran de télévision ça c'est un autre
problème de fait c'est techniquement
possible
nous le ferons certainement mais je
dirais que cette vidéo fournie en
quelque sorte existe déjà mais cela se
fera certainement il existait déjà mais
pas assez mais c'est tellement ne vont
pas chez monsieur tout le monde mais
cela se fera et je ferai ce que je
demande c'est monsieur tout le monde que
celui qui le voudra et le qu'on peut
dire que dans la décennie qui vient ce
progrès sera organisée est ce que le
développement de cette télématique ne
risque pas d'aggraver encore le fossé
qu'il ya entre nous autres les riches
et les pauvres les démunis du progrès
les pays riches ne connaissent pas c'est
la misère d'autrui il dit à l'eau passe
par conséquent tout moyen de
communication entre les hommes entre les
sociétés toutes les enrichissements du
dialogue qui va se faire
ce sera d'abord une meilleure
connaissance de la différence qu'il ya
est donc une incitation à lutter contre
ces différences et je crois que bien sûr
que sans doute un problème d'égoïsme qui
existe
viscéralement chez les hommes et les
jeunes et société il ya surtout un
problème de nos connaissances de cette
différence
alors tout ce que par le téléphone par
télévision par le mariage de téléphonie
la télévision en escale être afin de
mieux reconnaître à jouer en termes de
balance commerciale et je sais que vous
y intéressez très près la france
est-elle importatrice ou exportatrice de
télématique elle est déjà exportatrice
de façon générale dans le monde des
télécommunications
nous exportons à peu près 18 % de notre
comment dirais-je une autre chiffre
d'affaires dans l'industrie des
télécommunications
ce qui fait de l'ordre de 1 3 milliard
de francs par an nous avons déjà pour
cette année 79 ans comment près de 4
milliards et les choses vont augmenter
pour 80 de l'industrie des
télécommunications explorer pour 30% de
son chiffre d'affaires et j'ai fixé
comme objectif aux industries françaises
étaient des communications car
maintenant nous avons des industries
françaises de télécommunications un
objectif de 50 % à l'exportation de son
chiffre d'affaires c'est un pari
contiendra il le faut penser quelque
chose de considérable parce que ce que
nous exportons par tous moyens c'est
l'intelligence française
ce n'est pas de la matière première ce
n'est pas de l'énergie qu'on devrait
acheter par ailleurs c'est vraiment
pratiquement le savoir faire français
la télématique va-t-elle favoriser la
décentralisation des décisions ou sera
t-elle au contraire un nouveau facteur
de concentration du pouvoir
je dois dire que fatalement mais même
politique par nous voulons fatalement
c'est le seul moyen de décentraliser le
pouvoir
pourquoi il y à pouvoir quand il y à
savoir et pour qu'il y ait savoir il
faut publier justement une possibilité
d'avoir communication avec ses gros
sabots de renseignement de les avoir
tout de suite et de les avoir dans
l'actualité puis parfaite et ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes qui justement aux
hébreux centre douvres d'aller non il y
avoit y est vous pouvoir concentré quand
la concentration des moyens de savoir
avec a poussé avec la possibilité de le
communiquer à autrui dans la mesure où
au contraire chacun peut savoir
chacun peut donc critiqué dans la mesure
où en province il y aura le même axe et
à paris pour dire le mot aux sources du
savoir
il y aura un pouvoir qui pourraient
déléguer ses efficacement et le facteur
dans tout ça je prends le facteur comme
le symbole de la personne qui pourrait
ne plus être employé la perte d'emploi
ah non ça ne ment pas d'ailleurs il est
logique de voir que si on crée des
produits nouveaux c'est donc des emplois
nouveaux que l'on va créer
par exemple il est évident que le
développement de ce qu'on appelle les
produits nouveaux c'est à dire ne poste
à clavier l'écran de télévision qui va
être liés à la panne de téléphone va
dans les années qui viennent créer 8000
emplois nouveaux que l'augmentation de
l'exportation
c'est aussi que 8000 emplois nouveaux
dans quelques années qui viennent qui
vont être créés et qui vont compenser
largement une pub dans quoi que l'on
pourrait on doit prévoir par suite du
fait qu' il faut moins de personnes pour
sa part électronique que pour faire des
appareils avec trois mécanismes tels
faits les personnes plus spécialisés ça
que j'aimais aussi dans la perte
d'emplois il n'y a pas de pertes
d'emplois certainement pas et il ya
surtout un angle bisman du travail de
l'homme un enrichissement de la
personnalité qui non seulement se
traduira dans le travail et dans la vie
profitant la vie personnelle des êtres
des personnes je crois que c'est la
grande richesse de près poc
cette croissance du savoir des hommes
mal monde scientifique avec des
connaissances augmente à peu près tous
les cinq ans le double à peu près tous
les cinq ans je veux dire plus eh bien
regardez comment les jeunes en
particulier s'adapte fita secondaire ils
savent beaucoup de choses
ils ont appelé sens critique puis
développé ça peut être énervant mais
combien c'est beau et efficace et par
conséquent je suis persuadé que ces
techniques nouvelles qui créeront plus
d'emplois en fait qu'elle n'en supprime
rond mais le feront dans des techniques
nouvelles
nécessitant plus d'intelligence ça
devait space a du coeur injustement
puisque vous me répondez comme ça je
vous pose la dernière question est ce
que nous serons plus heureux
être heureux c'est quand même quelque
chose de personnel il ya des gens qui
sont naturellement malheureux alors
qu'ils ont énormément de choses et il ya
des gens qui sont naturellement madeloc
heureux alors qu ils vivent dans un
temps si certaines pauvreté j'allais
dire pour moi personnellement m'enfin je
suis j'étais un ami personnel du père
teilhard de chardin et par conséquent je
crois que le bonheur réside surtout dans
l'enrichissement au niveau spirituel de
l'être ne voyons pas vers sydney est-ce
que la clé nati qui nous prêtent à un
monde meilleur
fatalement puisque l occm ap les
communications entre les hommes de dents
en quantité et en qualité
et je pense que on est plus heureux
quand on est moins refermer sur soi même
quand on est plus ouvert vers autrui
quand on dit alors davantage avec la
nature et avec les hommes avec d'autres
hommes pour d'autres philosophies notre
histoire car c'est ça le véritable
bonheur mais c'est comprendre truite
lettre ouverte à l'an 2000 avec comme
invité monsieur norbert segard le
secrétaire d'état aux ptt qui répondait
aux questions bêtes idiot le prochain
journal est à 20 heures il sera présenté
par